Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the final and closing verse of surah
al
chapter number 73
verse number 20.
This is a longer verse. It's the longest
verse in the chapter. And at first
glance,
this verse
seemingly doesn't match up with the
rhythm of all of the previous verses.
Meaning
there's a big distinction and a very
deep difference between
and a very fundamental difference
and distinction between the Meccan
chapters and the Medini chapters.
Chapters that were revealed
prior to Hijra are referred to as Mecci.
chapters that were revealed after the
event of Hijra are referred to as Medi.
Those two eras because Mecc Mecc and
Medanin, as we've mentioned before, this
is not a reference to a place. It's a
reference to a time, an era. So, we have
the the Mechi
epic or era and then we have the Medani
epic or era. And these two eras have
very distinct
verses, very distinct subject
matters, very distinct
very distinct
context
to one another.
One, we have the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and his companions
living as a minority
amongst a majority
of aggressive
non-Muslims and combative non-Muslims.
Then we have in Medina, they're still
somewhat a minority
though they were the growing major their
majority was growing very fast and very
quickly.
But now they are no longer just a
subject. They're no longer subjects to
another king or another rule. Now they
are at the helm of beginning their own
state. And so these two eras have very
differentloop.
They have very different with respect
to the Quran. You can see a very
distinct difference in even the length
of the verses, the subject matter of the
verses, even the language and diction of
the verses are very distinct and
different.
For this reason,
the scholars may differ somewhat on
which verses are Medani and which verses
are mechi.
We have a general rule, general
principle
and that is
that
when a chapter is revealed in Mecca, it
starts being revealed in Mecca
is that all of the chapter is Mecci.
And if a chapter is revealed in Medina,
all of the chapter is going to be Medi.
But that is not an absolute rule.
There are some chapters that are
predominantly mechi but have Medani
elements or verses and vice versa. There
are chapters which are predominantly
Medani but have what? Mechan verses.
Understanding this is very important and
the scholars have taken great pains
to ensure
documenting
and scouring every corner of the books
of history and the books of hadith
in search of identifying exactly which
chapters and which verses were revealed
in which era. Why is that so important?
Why is it so important
that we identify
what was revealed in Mecca versus what
was revealed in Medina? Who wants to
take a go at that? Why is that so
detrimental?
Or why is that so important
and so
of such importance that it warrants such
precision from the scholarship of Islam
[Arabic recitation]
information.
And what is the most important
determining factor with respect to the
meanings of words? Context. Correct? I
mean, think about it. Context is more
important than the actual words that are
even said. Context can be more important
than the actual words that are said. Let
me give you an example.
Let's say
somebody
let's say you were to ask me about a a
person or you know let's say a
particular thing you're to ask me about
this what do you think about this do you
this or you don't it and I say
I love it that I love this
compare Compare that to I love it.
Right. Oh, I love that.
You notice the difference in tone? You
notice the different body language?
That's context. One
is taken to mean, yes, he loves that
thing. The other is taken to mean
exactly the opposite of what the words
themselves say. It's what we call
sarcasm. Correct?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
he's saying this to the people of the
hellfire as they're getting molten
hellfire poured on their heads.
It will be said to them, "Taste this.
Indeed, you are the honorable and you
are the noble.
How is it? Look how the meanings are
clashing here. We've got hellfire poured
on his head, which is the lowest of
humiliation.
And then it said to him, you are the
noble. You are the, you know, the things
that used to be chanted by their minions
to them in the dunya. This is what we
call in Arabic, which is sarcasm, right?
It's sarcasm. That word that that
statement on its own, we wouldn't
understand that if it weren't for the
context.
When we have a verse that is revealed in
the context of Mecca, radically
different connotations,
radically different
meanings are derived from the words
of that verse as opposed to if they were
revealed in Medina.
Mecca and Medani is one of the most
important sciences of the Quran. So much
so that we don't even have that just
with the Quran but we also have that
with the Sunnah.
But with the Sunnah it is less difficult
because most of the time the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam is saying
something
to a person whether it's the narrator of
the hadith himself that provides context
or an event that is happening. So the
context is usually self-evident, but in
the Quran, we're not sure. We have to be
given that context. And so
identifying what is Mecc and what is
Medani is the difference between
is the it can potentially hold the
same difference that our example in our
analogy gave of use of sarcasm. For
instance, right? If I were to say for
you, if I were to say to you,
,
I really admire this person, and then I
were to say, oh, I really admire this
guy. Right? That just those ways that
I'm saying it, the in intonation, the
the inflection in my voice changes the
entire meaning, even though the words
themselves are exactly the same.
Correct?
That is why mechi and medin is so
critical. Now in identifying mechi and
medi the scholars have rules of thumb
that they use. So they say okay if we
were to gather all of the verses that
are mechi and all of the verses that are
medin that we are positive this was
revealed in Mecca and this is revealed
in Medina.
and we were to compare those two.
So for instance,
we are positive it was revealed in
Mecca.
We are positive it was revealed as a
Medani chapter. It was revealed in Mecca
but during the Medani era. If we were to
compare these two chapters, we would see
very distinct differences.
So the scholars did what? They took all
the chapters that they know are Mecci
for sure. There's no difference of
opinion.
And they took all the chapters that are
Medani and are agreed upon amongst the
scholarship of Islam as being Medani.
And then they compared those two and
came up with a couple of key differences
that are found to distinguish between
the Meccin and Medini. Then there's
another group that is different upon.
Some say it's Meccin, some say it's
Medini. And so they try to apply those
rules to this other group of chapters or
verses that are Mech. And one of those
is the length of the verses.
When we look at Mechi chapters, the
verses are usually following a very
particular rhyme scheme,
meaning the ends of the verses, they're
all similar and usually they the
verses even have the same amount of
syllables in them and they have a very
particular rhythm to them. And even the
letters that are used in the Meccan
chapters are different than the letters
used in the Medani chapters. Think
for instance
all of the chapter follows this same
kind of rhythm and this same kind kind
of rhyme scheme. Then you switch over to
something Bakar very different
radically different. The longest verse
in the Quran is inah Bakar, right? Also,
the subject matter,
all of the
details of the Islamic law, all of the
details of Islamic law and
so forth were all revealed where in
Medina except for salah and a few other
things. But what did Mecca really the
Meccan era really focus on? The main
thing it focused on what was it?
The worship of Allah alone without any
partners. This is the center thrust of
that era and
honesty, dignity, courage, valor, ,
generosity,
selflessness.
, and then things are looked at in a
very general sense. People of hell,
people of paradise, right? That there's
there's very little gradation there
between the two. That's how the Meccan
era was. The Medani era we have a lot of
details. All the three remaining
pillars of Islam were in Medina, Zaka
and fasting and Hajj and Omrah. Also
when it comes to halal and haram and
this is permissible, this is
impermissible etc. All those generals
general things were filled in those
details were filled in where? in Medina.
When we look at this last verse, when
you read the of the scholars on
you, you'll see that they will say many
of them will say
they'll say this is a Meccan chapter
except for the last verse. The last
verse, the last verse is a Medini
chapter. Why? Well, one of those things,
one of those reasons immediately jumps
out at you is what? The length of the
verses, right? The the start of the
chapter, we have about one line, one and
a quarter line. This is the the average
length of the verses. They follow a very
particular rhyme scheme and they have a
certain amount of syllables to them. We
get to the last verse and it's one long
verse that is half a page long. Second
of all, it has mention of jihad in it,
right? as we'll get to, it has mention
of Zaka in it, which we said when was
Zakiah obligated
in Medina, right?
But that isn't all the way correct
because there are verses that we are
100% sure are Meccan verses, but they
speak about Zakya.
How how do we harmonize that? Well, just
like
just like
the general obligations of Islam were
mentioned in Mecca and then filled out
later in Medina. So for instance,
things that are permissible to eat and
impermissible to eat. In Mecca,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions three
main things.
these three, right? And then the rest is
all
anything that is filthy, anything that
is
bad for your body or anything that is
right.
Then when we get to Medina, then we
start having the rulings of how
slaughtering is to be done. And we have
the rulings of the the the food of a the
the slaughtered meat of a Jew or a
Christian. And we have the details of
anything that has talons, right, that it
hunts with or any beast that has you
know fangs that it uses to hunt with.
All those things came later. So in Mecca
we have a general thing and then in
Medina we have what details that are
filled in. They fit together perfectly.
And when we call people to Islam and
when people first become Muslim we
follow the same formula.
We follow the same formula. That's why
it's so important as to how these things
are documented. The same thing with
zakia. Zaka
was commanded in Mecca, but it wasn't
commanded 2.5%
and once a year or during harvest, etc.,
etc. These details were filled in in
Medina.
What was made obligatory in Mecca was
what? General charity.
And we're going to call this general
charity, zak.
And so this is the method that is used
when we look at this verse.
The scholars some of them say this is a
medin verse.
What do they cite for that? Is there any
particular
evidence a narration
something solid unambiguous? No. It's
only these general trends. They say it
doesn't really match up with the pattern
of Mecca. It is matches up with the
Medani pattern. But really that's not a
strong enough evidence.
And for this reason a good portion
including
are of the view that this verse is a
mechan verse
and the mention of zak
and the mention of jihad which were only
obligated way later in Medina. These
were actually
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala was
mentioning these things
in order for to kind of plant the seed
that when we arrive at Medina don't
worry jihad will be a thing just not yet
right zaka will be a thing just not yet
not in this particular way in Mecca you
got to remember And we'll end with this
inshallah. You got to remember in Mecca
a lot especially the younger men right
right
you know the the the younger guys
who was very young. He was about 28
right in in in Mecca or there
thereabouts.
these younger men, they have a lot more
emotion than they do experience,
right? And this is why Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala didn't test us by having all
of us be here all at once at the same
time because we we complete each other.
The elders give us wisdom. The youth
give us vigor,
right? They're emotion. They're
emotional. They want to make their, you
know, I want to make my mark on this
earth and I'm going to you know pound in
the chest and you know how they get that
we need that but we needed to be
controlled by the wisdom of the elders
right and the elders very wise but
dragging their feet cuz life has beat
them beat them up right they're tired
and they they've given up on a lot of
stuff so we need the youth to come and
jolt them awake Right. In Mecca, the
youth were very the same exact thing was
going on. They were seeing the Muslims,
their brothers and sisters being
tortured. Some of them tortured to
death.
And they're constantly saying to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam, let
us fight. Let us do this. Come on. I
could do this. I could How about if we
wait at the outskirts of Mecca and
anybody that leaves, we can intercept
them. What about if we do this? What
about if they don't know who it is? What
about if and the prophet sallallam is
saying what
right?
So they are amped up. They want to
fight
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tempers
that a little bit how by giving by
giving indicators that this will
eventually be a thing. Not right now.
Its time will come. And when its time
comes, we're going to need you to put
your money where your mouth is. You're
going to need to walk the walk. But
until then, you need to fight yourself
by controlling yourself. And so that's
why there are verses that mention things
that haven't yet been fleshed out in
Mecca and will be fleshed out in Medina.
So that on its own is not enough to
discount a verse from being a Medani
or a Mecci verse. We will continue this
inshall tomorrow night.
[Silence]
How are you?